foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I'm here with my
good friend TK Coleman what it is
malabama is here hi everybody Ryan
Nicodemus is on vacation this week but
he will be back next week for episode
400. coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking to a
couple of listeners about Hobby clutter
and a new strategy to figure out what's
truly important in your life then we've
got our lightning round segment a live
stream question and a listener tip for
you you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 399 where we
answer five times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
advertisements suck yes they do let's
start with our callers today if you have
a question or a comment for our show
give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice recording
to podcasts at the minimalists.com our
first question of the day is from Mike
this is Mike from Tallahassee
um I was wondering if you have a hobby
and you make a checklist of purchase
that support your hobbies should you
fulfill that checklist thanks
TK tell me what you what your thoughts
are on checklists
the first question that pops in my mind
when I think about any checklist is is
it yours
I often tell my students follow your
dreams but make sure they're your dreams
that you're following
because it's easy to orient your life
around memetic desire you're chasing
things you're following to-do lists
you're obeying a bunch of rules you're
pursuing projects and none of that stuff
is coming from the heart it's a bunch of
stuff that you think you ought to do or
that other people told you would be good
for you to do but you want to pursue
things in life that you don't have to
justify right you know if I were to say
something like hey man I got a good
friend his birthday's coming up I want
to take him out for a cup of coffee I
want to buy him a book that I know that
he really wants uh is it okay if I do
those things should I do it I really
love my wife and I got a bunch of things
I want to do for I want to buy her a
flower I want to take her out to dinner
should I do that when you found
something or someone that you love you
don't agonize over those chess lists
over those checklists because you just
organically Express the love and
affection that you have by doing what
you want to do right and so find the
hobbies that you don't need to justify
pursue the things pursue the people that
make you just want to say yes to it from
a place of I love it this is what I want
to do and this feels free you know what
I mean I think we get really caught up
in the shoulds of it right he even said
should I get everything on my checklist
do everything on my checklist and of
course there are no shoulds but there
are unlimited infinite Goods there are
many things you could do and I think
about different hobbies that people have
and some have hobbies they require
accoutrements right if you are going to
hike Mount Everest you probably need
more things than I need as a person who
doesn't climb mountains right now is it
possible to hike Everest with just
shorts on like a Wim Hof did yeah I
guess right but most people's
experiences will be what enhanced by
having the appropriate accessories the
question I often might ask myself is
what would happen if you go without
because if I go without doesn't mean I
should go without what would happen if I
go without maybe my experience will be
enhanced maybe my creativity will be
expanded in my hobby because I Had
Creative limitations that were birthed
out of the boundaries that I have maybe
I don't have all the accessories that I
thought I needed but it turns out I
didn't need those accessories at all I
thought I needed them because Society
told me I needed them or I created a
checklist of all the things on my dream
list that I might want for this hobby
yeah and who knows the hobby might be
something you just started and now
you're going to buy all of these
different accessories to fulfill a hobby
you may not be that interested in in the
first place and so I want to discuss
with Mike the diminishing returns of
owning too much
because there is a sweet spot for any
hobby that you have if you are a runner
having shoes May enhance your running
now the Barefoot Runners will disagree
with that obviously right and they even
call into question okay what would
happen if you went without well yeah I
would still run I would just do it
Barefoot and maybe my life is better
running Barefoot someone else if I say
nope I injured myself doing that I need
Minimalist Shoes for that okay that are
that are zero drop or the Little Five
Finger shoes or whatever it might be
that's fine or maybe I just need a
regular pair of Adidas or Nikes or
Reeboks or filos or whatever to help me
run okay what do I need to be on a lot
of course I need the correct windbreaker
for this and I need the performance
shorts that are sweat wicking and now
all of a sudden for something as simple
as running I have a list of a dozen
things that I must have otherwise I am
not a runner well no you are a runner if
you run you are a writer if you write it
doesn't matter what accoutrements you
have what accessories you have and you
accept your accessories they can
definitely enhance the experience but
there's also a point of diminishing
returns there's a point where those
accessories actually get in the way yeah
I'm thinking about if you buy all of the
running accessories and you're wearing
them all over your body in fact Danny
was just running a marathon this weekend
Danny can you imagine if you were to
Adorn your whole body with more
accessories I need the watch that tracks
everything perfectly I need to sync that
up with the app and everything else it
actually gets in the way of the thing
that you want to do which is run
and so is this getting in the way if so
I probably don't want to bring it on
into my even if it's on my checklist
yeah so I'd look at that whole checklist
if I were in Mike's shoes and I would
say hey are any of these things going to
get in the way and then I would ask what
would happen if I went without this not
forever but what if I went without it
for a month or three months what's going
to happen and push yourself as far as
the pushing feels free don't push
yourself because Josh is telling you to
push yourself don't push yourself
because there's this sense of guilt that
says well as a minimalist I should try
really really hard to run without a pair
a pair of gym shoes right a hobby is
something that presumably you're going
to do more than once right it's not like
an experiment hey I'm getting ready to
go on my first camping trip ever I have
no clue what sorts of things to expect
hey friends those of you who have gone
camping can you give me a checklist of
the things that I might need and then
I'll think about it you know it this is
something that I enjoy I want to do more
and more off and so the checklist is
only there to support the enjoyment you
make a checklist because there are
things that are important to you and you
don't want to forget them amidst the
hustle and bustle of life you don't want
to get out there and be in the middle of
running and go oh no I want it to bring
a bottle of water and I forgot it the
whole point is you check your list the
list represents things that you put down
because they matter to you they enhance
the experience right and so what
enhances your experience what gives you
Joy eliminate as much as you can but
nothing less than what keeps that
experience meaningful for you because if
you're checklist is stripping away the
hobby of its meaning then you're you're
losing the point you're sacrificing the
why for the how yeah and I want to talk
about some individual hobbies that might
require more accessories as well and I
think that's important to acknowledge
but even in those scenarios when you're
first starting out let's say you're
going camping my wife is an avid camper
she really enjoys camping I don't I grew
up poor I don't know why I want to
recreate that now I like having a roof
over my head and and I don't like
sleeping on the ground and so I but I
that's not a judgment on her she really
enjoys it and I respect the fact that in
fact I really appreciate the fact that
she gets joy out of that you don't like
the nature aspect of it just like I do I
like I like being outside and being in
nature but then I like going home to
sleep
I don't like sleeping with the Bears I
get it but here's the thing let's say
you're taking up a new hobby like
camping you don't want to go out and
spend two thousand dollars on new
camping accessories you don't even know
if you like this hobby yet right right
so the question I ask myself is there a
free alternative yeah okay maybe there's
somewhere I can actually get some of
this stuff for free that I need or maybe
I can borrow it from a friend a family
member or Craigslist maybe I can get it
used is that possible right and maybe I
can even rent it for a period of time
we've done that with different equipment
for filming things that we do whenever
we need to film a new movie we don't go
out and buy all the cameras you rent
that for a few days when you need it now
if you need to buy a camera because in
the studio we use cameras every week it
made more sense for us to buy the
cameras here once we knew that we would
be using them regularly but you don't
just go out and say you know what I'm
thinking about starting a podcast let's
spend thirty thousand dollars on
equipment that's what people do they
think that the equipment is going to
translate into a high quality
conversation but sometimes that will get
in the way I'll use one more example for
you writing I write and I require
accessories for writing in fact I'm
holding a pin in my hand right now and I
have a piece of paper here in front of
me and so that is what I need to write
now usually I write on my computer any
computer will generally do just fine any
software program will do just fine for
me usually free software programs like
Google Docs or Apple notes that works
great for me however our good friend
Professor Sean he teaches me how to
write better class with me he really
enjoys the accoutrements of writing
whether it's the electronic
accoutrements of like a tablet that
works really well for him I don't like
tablets at all so a tablet for me would
get in the way and recently he's gotten
into using really high-end pins and
notebooks he has a really nice fountain
pen that costs more than all of my pins
combined and I don't think he's wrong
for that but what works for me may not
work for we that's right and what I've
learned is that if I were to go mimic
exactly what Sean does it would actually
getting in the get in the way of my
writing process and I think that's
important will these accessories get in
the way of your hobby if so their
clutter yeah I I think there's a nice
little distinction arising out of this
and that is will I enjoy this and then
if the answer to that is yes how will I
enjoy this because you and I can both
enjoy the same thing but perhaps we in
enjoy it in different ways right maybe
we both like to go see shows but I like
to see movies and you like to see live
theater maybe I like to snack and eat
popcorn when I'm watching a movie maybe
you don't enjoy eating anything at all
because that gets in the way of the
Aesthetics of the experience while you
watch the story unfold and so I I think
what's coming out of this is strive to
be as minimalist as you possibly can
early on in the process as you get to
know that Hobby and as you get to know
yourself in relation to that Hobby and
then once you got that figured out you
know what to invest and you won't be
over committing that's so important
that's this makes me think of when I
first discovered people that would do
very elaborate letter writing and
YouTube is great for this to introduce
you to a wide variety of hobbies but I
would see these people that would pull
out beautiful different shades of paper
all of these little tapes and stickers
and all kinds of stuff and it was like a
collage where they would letter write
and they'd film themselves doing this
and I went oh that's gorgeous I want to
do that and I started buying all the
things I was like well I need some
stickers to put in there and I get in
front of the paper and go I don't know
what to write I think I just really
enjoyed watching other people do this
and that's really okay is finding out
that explanation of do I just enjoy this
existing do I enjoy interacting with
this and watching it or is this
something that I feel compelled to do
and if so what's the bare minimum I need
to start to see if you like it to even
go into it that's so good and of course
there will be Ebbs and flows throughout
all of this I've seen Jordan no more
over there and he is a minimalist
filmmaker and you can give him next to
nothing give him a tin can he'll make a
movie out of it somehow but also he is
genius right obsessed with a lot of the
accoutrements that wouldn't they don't
mean anything to me he has a really nice
camera that he just bought recently and
when I say there are Ebbs and flows just
like minimalism when you let go of the
excess in your closet what happens
eventually it becomes full of new things
and so it's a process of acquiring
Letting Go acquiring letting go if
you've got all the things for camping
over a period of time then you realize
like not all of these are really serving
me the way I thought they were or they
did serve me but I'm doing this
differently now a willingness to let go
is so important
Mike I want to give you something in
fact anyone who's listening to this they
can download it for free we have these
minimalist wallpapers you can download
for free and one of them is the five
questions to ask before buying and I
think that's especially important for a
hobby because Hobbies we get really
excited about and we throw all
discretion out the window and say I need
all the accessories and I need them
right now one click it'll be on my
doorstep by tomorrow and great my life
will be fulfilled I'll have all the
camping gear so much so that I might not
ever even go camping right I fulfilled
my desire by just buying the things and
then of course it doesn't actually
fulfill your desire they tend to get in
the way so five questions to ask before
buying here are the five questions
can I afford to part with this money and
here's a hint if you have to charge it
to a credit card you cannot afford it
can I pay the actual cost remember the
true cost of a thing goes far beyond the
price tag all those things you buy you
have to store them you have to water
them you have to clean them you have to
take care of them you have to wash them
you have to worry about them those are
additional costs that go beyond the
price tag can you pay that actual cost
number three will it add value to my
life it must serve a purpose or amplify
your joy in some way otherwise it
doesn't add value in fact it might get
in the way of your hobby that'd be the
worst thing you buy something to improve
your hobby and it actually gets in the
way of that hobby number four what are
the Alternatives in other words is this
the best use of this money
if not maybe I can rent it maybe I can
borrow it for a period of time maybe I
can spend that money elsewhere if this
isn't the best use of that money and
then finally number five can I get by
without it for a while if so wait you
can always use our 30 30 rule yep if
something costs more than thirty dollars
wait at least 30 hours to buy it why is
that because it allows some friction in
the process we make it a little more
difficult to buy that thing to not act
on impulse because when we don't act on
impulse we're buying it intentionally so
you can download that right now over the
minimalists.com just click on the
resources page there you can find a
bunch of free resources from the
minimalist including seven different
wallpapers to declutter your smartphone
or your computer screen let's move on to
some social media questions we got one
from Instagram Zion has a question for
us if you aren't willing to go all in on
something is that a sign that it isn't
really that important to you
fundamentally I think the answer to that
is yes that's not a bad thing just
because something isn't important to you
doesn't mean that it should be important
to you right you know gardening is not
important to me I might I could try it a
little bit but it's not that important
so I'm not going to go all the way in
why because it's not that important to
me the way here's the way I think about
it TK if your home is being invaded you
cease to worry about doing the dishes
say it one more time if your home is
being invaded you cease to worry about
doing the dishes yeah that's right
because I'm trying to grab a dish and
whack the person upside down with it
throwing like a frisbee something has
become more important in that moment if
you're sitting there doing the dishes
and and someone breaks into your house
the thing that was important is no
longer important because there is
something that is more pressing in the
moment and so something that's important
to me like writing I treat it like a
home invasion
nothing else is going to stop me from
doing it because someone's breaking into
my house right now I'm not like yeah but
hey can you hold on I have to mow the
lawn
yeah hey can you hold on I was just
mopping the floors
no I go all the way in because it
writing is important to me uh but I'm
sick today yeah it's a home invasion
doesn't matter if I am sick if someone
is breaking into my home I'm going to do
whatever it takes to handle it's the
most important thing in my life it is
literally the priority and that's why we
don't have priorities it's nonsensical
to think about the word priorities as a
plural it wasn't a plural until the 20th
century you can't have 20 priorities
priority means the first thing you can't
have 20 the first things if something is
truly important to you in this moment it
is the priority and nothing else is the
priority and I treat anything that is
important to me like it's a home
invasion someone's breaking into my home
and right now writing is that thing for
me right now podcasting is that thing
I'm not worried about the other things I
forgot to pay the bills I leave the
stove on whatever it doesn't matter her
right now podcasting In This Moment is
the priority there's no other priority
in this moment yeah and so stick with
that analogy about the the home invasion
suppose I'm in the middle of doing my
dishes and then an Invader comes in and
I turn into Jon Jones Conor McGregor and
I choke him out right and then my wife
sees the dishes undone she says you
don't care about the dishes I'd be like
come on now I just choked out I just
turned into Conor McGregor Jon Jones can
you appreciate the Artistry of what I
did to this guy I just did him my John
Moran would have oh God he's in the
kitchen floor with him and an arm bar
going really got him in the Triangle
the moral of the story uh as terrible as
the story is the moral of the story is
that just because something else in your
life might take priority over this other
thing it doesn't mean there is no place
for that other thing it doesn't mean
that you don't care about that other
thing it doesn't mean you should beat
yourself up about not caring about that
right now so when you don't go all in on
something that doesn't mean you don't
love it or it has no place in your life
it could mean that there are other
matters in your life right now more
urgent that need to be taken care of or
it could also mean that
it's only a value to you to do that
thing if you can do it in a way that's
right for you one of the problems with
the way we think about passion is we
tend to think to think about it in
isolation but there is no one who loves
anything independently of any
consideration whatsoever I love baseball
that doesn't mean I want to watch a
baseball game at three in the morning
right I love writing that doesn't mean I
enjoy writing about any Topic at any
time for any reason everything that we
love has conditions around it that are
necessary to sustain the energy of that
love and so sometimes when we find a lot
of resistance going on with these things
that we know we love but we have a hard
time doing it may be because we're
trying to do those things in a way
that's too scripted too conventional to
in accordance with someone else's
expectations or According to some story
we're telling ourselves about how it
always has been done and what might be
needed is to step back and say What's
the best way for me to do this thing and
what's a good amount of it for me to do
that works for the life that I have
that's good yeah because the alternative
to that is to let everyone else's
important task dictate your day and
that's quite often what we do our inbox
becomes the repository of things we
should do but our inbox is only filled
by other people's requests other
people's needs nothing wrong with that
they're expressing their needs to you
great but if 24 hours of my day is
dictated by the needs of other people
when are my needs being met yeah
Alabama what time is it it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
questions from Tick Tock yes indeed you
can follow the minimalist on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook and Twitter we're at
the minimalist during the lightning
round we each have 60 seconds to answer
your question with a short shareable
less than 140 character response and we
put the minimal maxims that we utter
here today in the show notes over at the
minimalists.com so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if you like today's question comes from
melon how do we redirect negative
thoughts that come up when we look at
possessions that are holding us back we
got a 60-second shot clock on uh up
there for our good friend TK Coleman
what do you got for us TK
negative reactions to negative thoughts
produce more negative results there are
moments in life when we simply have to
confront or consider information that
feels unpleasant the doctor says your
leg is broken you need surgery a company
you enjoy working for says we have to do
layoffs and part ways a lover says I
don't love you anymore infinite
variations but you get the point
sometimes the truth hurts but it's
important to remember that it always
helps and it always heals and if we
treat the truth like it's a threat just
because it doesn't feel good to hear we
rob ourselves of the opportunity to get
the help and the healing that we need to
become the person that we need to be Dr
Zach Bush said on this show that our
pain is a gift because it's what allows
our nervous system to do the kind of
communication that's necessary for the
body to repair itself the same is true
of the heart the mind the soul our pain
is a gift that's not just some bit of
forced optimism so when you have
negative thoughts about things in your
life that's holding you back you don't
have to force yourself to feel positive
about it instead you can confront the
truth and do whatever you got to do to
unpack the stories you're telling
yourself and to let go of the things
that are stopping you from being healthy
and free that's so good you reminded me
of uh Wayne Dyer he said that the snake
bite is never the thing that kills you
it's always the Venom that begins to
course through your veins well those
negative thoughts that you're talking
about TK that is the Venom it's not the
event that calls the negative thoughts
that's killing you it's those negative
thoughts that perpetuate more negative
thoughts and now it's a spiral a
downward spiral of negativity so I've
got some of the pity for you give me 60
seconds Professor Sean
positive thoughts are the source of not
the antidote to negative thoughts
positive thoughts and negative thoughts
are water from the same well of course
one is preferable to the other Buddhists
would say useful thoughts and not useful
thoughts unuseful thoughts right and so
I don't need to moralize my thoughts
this one's good this one's bad but there
are many thoughts that are useful that I
have there are many that are unuseful
and if I need one I'm probably going to
get the others if I need the positive
feedback on Twitter or on the YouTube
comments I'm going to find the negative
in that right but if I no longer need
the positive what happens the negative
ceases to have that same weight so I
picked the answer for you although I do
want to bring Wayne Dyer back into the
conversation real quick I was thinking
about one of his quotes
if you change the way you look at things
the things you look at change and so
yes something happened to you and it's
causing all of these negative thoughts
these bad emotions I feel awful but what
if I change the way that I look at that
maybe that event maybe my mother dying
as awful as that was as negative as that
was was a blessing for the rest of my
life maybe it forced me to start
questioning my material possessions it
forced me to question my relationships
and my career it put things into
perspective
that's just me looking at it a different
way and when I look at it in that way it
changes everything that's right you know
that's how I've always seen the phrase
turn the other cheek and I I don't claim
to speak with any Authority here and
offer some like official interpretation
that other people need to believe but
but I've always seen that statement like
if someone strikes you on One Cheek turn
the other cheek well what do you have to
physically do to turn the other cheek if
if you're if you strike this cheek and
I've got to do a 180 shift I've got to
look in the opposite direction right and
so many times in life when it seems like
things are coming against you you're
experiencing the universe in an
adversarial way maybe look in the
opposite direction maybe shift your
perspective and get a different view on
it and you can change a relationship to
it and you can change the energy around
it and ultimately you can start
responding to things in a healthy and
empowering way we're gonna check in with
that patreon live stream here in a
moment but first real quick for right
here right now here's one or two or
maybe three things that are going on in
the life of the minimalists
did you know that you know a New York
Times best-selling author TK say what
no Sean and I we started a new YouTube
series over on the how to write better
YouTube channel I teach a writing class
called how to write better and we also
do these short little writing lessons
and people have been sending in their
questions and the new series is called
ask a best-selling writer I remember one
time someone said what gives you the
authority to teach a writing class I was
like well I've written five books four
of what you're best sellers and they're
like oh okay that sounds like a good
reason
because I don't just write about writing
I don't just talk about writing I
actually write books that a lot of
people find Value in and I've learned a
lot about my own writing style my own
recipe and I share those lessons and
this new series is called ask a
best-selling writer you can find it over
on the how to write better YouTube
channel we'll put a link to that in the
show notes or you can just head on over
to youtube.com how to write better and
speaking of how to write better I teach
a class two or three times a year the
summer semester launches July 7th that's
coming up really soon we opened up the
class for 48 hours only it's a four week
writing class how to write better.org if
you head over there you can find all the
information you can also download a free
ebook over there it's called 15 ways to
write better you can read it in less
than an hour and you'll walk away with
15 tips to improve your writing today
hey Josh you want to know what question
I ask what's that I never asked what
gives you you the authority to say XYZ I
ask what gives me the power to create
the results that matter most to me
answer good ideas do you have any if the
answer to that is yes I want them and I
don't give a damn who you are or where
you're from give me the good stuff yeah
and it doesn't matter to me where you
were accredited from or what certificate
you have do you have results that
resonate with me yeah and if that
resonates with you and if you are
someone who is a writer you're looking
to improve your writing got those free
video lessons over on the how to write
better YouTube channel or if you want to
take the course a limited to 48 Hours
only a hundred students as well so you
can find that at how to write better dot
org Alabama what else you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners oh by the way we're
looking for more listener insights we
are we've gone through our grab bag of
insights so if you have more comments
and tips or listener insights please
send your voice recording to podcast at
the min lists.com so we can feature your
beautiful voice on a future episode all
right here's that insight
I have a section of the closet where I
put clothes that are no longer my cup of
tea but are totally functional and when
I go to a different country or across
the country on a trip I bring those
clothes and I wear them usually looking
like a fool but I end up leaving them
either donating them or getting rid of
them if they're true they are garbage
and ready to go and this is a way of
rewarding myself for coming home with a
lighter bag and maybe not even a bag
although you do need to be careful about
doing that coming from a different
country because you will get flagged
anyway fun tip makes it a little more
palatable
um Good Luck all right y'all we'll see
you on patreon for the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 399 which
includes answers to a bunch more
questions like what are the minimalist
thoughts about the downsides of
capitalism
in what areas of life are the
minimalists not minimalists hmm
one of the three most common types of
paper clutter and how can you eliminate
all of them and a million more questions
for the minimalists also this week a
private minimalist home tour from one of
our listeners a calming living room with
zero excess in Los Angeles plus much
much more of less and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast at patreon.com the
minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain access to all of
our podcast archives all the way back to
episode zero zero one and if you're
still on the fence did you know that
patreon is now offering free trials so
if you'd like to test drive our private
podcast you can join for seven days for
free there's never been a better time to
try it out and that is our minimal
episode for today if you leave here
today with just one message please
let it be this
love people
use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it